So, notice that we took our orange circle with the center at 0, 0 and we moved
its center to 20, 0. We also moved the other four points, so we can connect
them to form a new circle that's been shifted 20 units to the right. But what
I'm wondering is what's the equation that would represent this circle? We know
we can't use this equation since it represents the circle centered at the
origin. We also know that this equation cant be right for our new circle since
if we plug in the points 70, 0 into the equation, it doesn't check. The x value
is too large. Keep in mind that this point was at 50, 0 and the y value still
was 0. But the x value changed to 70. Which made this too big, and it made our
equation not check. So what I want you to think about is, what would be the
equation for our new circle centered at the point 20, 0? I want you to enter
that equation here. Now I want to acknowledge that this is a really tough
question. You want to think about if the radius changed at all, or if the x
values changed or the y values changed. We need to adjust one of them. Which
one do you think we should adjust and by how much? Take some time to think
about it, and if you'd like, you can always play around on decimals and enter
your own equations to see how circles move. You're not expected to get
everything right on your first try, you're just expected to think and learn
about math.